hi my name is manoj ladwa I'm the
partner at mls chase I'm attending the
World Economic Forum on India for the
first time and it's been a fantastic
experience for me meeting people from
around the world who recognize that
India is a country that's on the move it
needs to make certain changes in order
to fulfill its potential but it's
definitely a country that's taking the
world stage by storm and I believe that
the deliberations today will set the
agenda for the coming months and coming
years of making india a country not only
of potential but of real change that can
affect not only the lives of people in
this country but around the world that's
what makes this forum especially
interesting exciting for me